- [Tricia] Do you know
who's hosting this year?
- Snoop Dogg?
(triumphant music)
Okay, okay.
So it's not.
- [Tricia] The city.
- Oh, you mean like
hosting, like the person.
I feel like Snoop Dogg
is hosting everything.
So I'm like, so where do you think it is?
- [Tricia] Beijing.
I know it's in Beijing,
so I was making sure that you knew.
It was in Beijing.
So, game begins now.
(triumphant music)
Hey, what's up, y'all?
It is a big time of year for
us in the sporting community.
I say us because obviously
I'm a 2021 Sports Emmy winner,
not once, but twice over.
I won two.
We're Sports Emmy winners.
Whether it was a mistake
or not, I earned it
and I'm keeping them and
I'm not changing the plates
even when you send me the
correct ones Emmy people.
The 2022 Winter Olympics
are about to begin
on February 4th.
Everybody in PSE can watch on NBC.
You like that.
There are so many different
Winter Olympic sports,
but there are also
apparently so many sports
that used to be, but are no
longer in the Winter Olympics.
I don't know why they got kicked out.
These are questions.
So I'm being challenged to a game of,
is this a Winter Olympic sport?
Let's see if I can guess them.
Skeleton.
Is Skeleton a winter sport?
I'm gonna say, no.
How is Skeleton a winter sport?
I don't understand.
(buzzing noise)
Oh, it is.
Skeleton is a...
You felt good about your er.
You're wrong.
It's not in the script, I just enjoy it.
Skeleton is a Winter Olympic sport.
(ding)
Oh, I remember that.
I didn't know that's what that was called.
Skeleton is a current Winter Olympic sport
where a competitor rides
face-first down a frozen track
on a small sled known
as a skeleton bobsled.
Did not actually know the name of it,
but yes I do know this.
This always scares me.
This is like nightmares of like,
even in like elementary
school, people are like,
"I'm gonna go down the slide head first."
I'm like, "Why would you do that?"
Like, I feel like you're
going to break your neck.
Why risk it for a playground fun time?
Like I don't get it, but
people do what they do.
Skeleton is a sport.
A current one.
(triumphant drum beat)
Icicle Javelin.
I don't think Icicle Javelin is a sport,
but I really want it to be.
Like a big giant javelin.
I feel like this is a sport in
Frozen, in the movie, Frozen.
This is not a real sport.
(bell chiming)
Yeah, Icicle Javelin is
not a Winter Olympic sport,
but wouldn't it be fun?
(dramatic music)
Oh, Skijoring.
Skijoring.
Is Skijoring a Winter Olympic sport?
I don't even know what the hell it is.
Skijoring.
Skiing
Joring
I don't know.
I'm going to say, yes.
I'm gonna think Ski...
Maybe you're skiing and you're
trying to go through rings or
you're trying to aim for rings.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
I feel like I won the game of BS.
(bell chiming)
It is a former Winter Olympic sport.
Let's find out more.
(ding)
Oh, Skijoring is where a human on skis
is pulled by a galloping horse.
Skijoring was held solely at the
St. Moritz 1928 Winter Olympic Games.
That just seems like a lot of work.
I feel like that's why they got rid of it.
I'm really glad that's not one.
It seems weird, but also kind of miss it
because that'd be really fun.
- [Cowboy] Heehaw.
- And look at that cowboy.
He's like, come on.
I feel like this is what
people on ranches do
when they get just hammered.
And they're like, "I have
this really great idea.
I'm gonna pull you behind the horse."
(neighing horse)
(upbeat music)
Ski Ballet.
Is Ski Ballet a Winter Olympic sport?
I feel like you're going
to break your ankle.
That's like a dumb thing.
I feel like you slip and
fall and snow and ice.
Like why would Ski Ballet be a sport?
I'm going to say, no.
(buzzing sound)
(ding)
Oh, Ski Ballet is a former Winter Olympic.
Ski Ballet is a mixture of
figure skating and skiing.
Performing a two-minute
ballet-like routine
outdoors on skis.
On skis?
Demonstrated at the '88 and
'92 Winter Olympic games.
Well, it's probably not a thing anymore
because people are so confused.
I'm still confused by it.
Oh, my God.
(up tempo disco music)
Look how joyful.
Oh, my gosh.
That guy, he is like
♪ Fame, I'm gonna live forever ♪
That's amazing.
Oh, my God, that guy.
I'm going to picture him all day today.
(epic music)
Ice Sculpting.
Is competitive Ice Sculpting
a Winter Olympic sport?
If it's not, it should be.
I love sculptures.
I think it's the most amazing
thing to be able to do that.
I think that Ice Sculpting
should be if it's not,
I'm going to say, yes.
(buzzing sound)
Ah, it isn't.
(ding)
It's an art form.
I mean, you got to be strong to do it.
- [Tricia] What would you sculpt?
- What would I sculpt?
You.
(melodic music)
Trisha Farrow.
I would just sculpt her.
Ice Sculpting is not a
Winter Olympic sport.
Although people do compete in it.
Okay, so it's not, but it should be.
(dramatic music)
- Whoa, Biathlon?
Biathlon.
Is Biathlon a Winter Olympic sport?
What the hell is Biathlon?
Biathlon, hmm.
I'm gonna say,
okay, Biathlon,
so it's like a bunch of things, maybe.
If it is something because
it's like a triathlon.
Like, you know, like athlon,
I feel like it's maybe,
I'm going to say, no.
I'm going to say Biathlon is
not a Winter Olympic sport.
(buzzing sound)
- [Tricia] I just like that
you're like a triathlon.
Bi would be two.
- I know, but like what...
I know, that's what I was saying.
Wait, well, that's what I was saying
because like a triathlon.
So I thought maybe, but then I
was like, when is a biathlon?
What would they be doing?
The biathlon is a race that combines
cross-country skiing and rifle shooting.
Once again, is this a real thing still?
- [Tricia] Yes.
- I'm gonna watch this.
You know what'd be cooler,
it wasn't rifle shooting,
it was bow and arrow.
(upbeat epic music)
Oh, Kase Essen.
Kase Essen.
That was my German, Yurman.
Is Kase Essen a Winter Olympic sport?
I mean, first of all, what
the hell does Kase Essen mean?
So, I don't know.
I'm going to say, sure. Yeah.
(buzzing sound)
Oh, nope, it is not.
It is not a Winter Olympic sport.
What is it?
Kase Essen is just
German for eating cheese.
Oh, it's good.
I like cheese.
That's the end of the game.
I wasn't very good at it, but anyway,
good luck to everybody
in the Winter Olympics.
It's such a cool thing for
the family to sit around
and watch together.
Thank you for working so hard.
I know it's probably weird circumstances
that y'all are under because everybody is
because of, you know, the pandemic.
So thank you for all your hard work.
Thank you for entertaining us
and congratulations on
being an Olympic athlete.
- [Tricia] If you were to ever
compete in Winter Olympics,
what sport would you be good at?
- Oh, eating cheese, Kase Essen.
I will be eating some
cheese and enjoying a
(speaking French) with some pinot noir
while watching you be athletic.
(triumphant music plays out)